make no mistake the 75 million americans
who voted
for president trump they're not going
away i'm one of them
i'm not going away either although many
on the left would probably love that
our conservative values they're not
going away our dedication to the
constitution
that's not going away our love of
freedom and justice for all
that's not going away either look at
this crowd
when he arrived in florida we're going
to show you
more of it coming up later and also
we're following the story out of
portland and seattle
i guess we don't have the video yet all
right coming up we'll talk about the
future of
the america first make america great
conservatism
and the republican party but first like
it or not democrats are now
in control of all branches of government
and the white house this morning joe
biden was sworn in as the 46th president
of the united states
and by the way in his first address to
the nation joe predictably
meandered his way through what is a
truly
unremarkable totally forgettable even
pre-rehearsed set of remarks
let's be honest the rest of the media
mob they were just flat out lying to the
american people
as per usual this was not in any way
shape matter or form
a memorable speech it will not be talked
about
decades to come frankly to be blunt
it's already forgotten even bill clinton
seemed to be falling yeah it looks like
he's nodding off there take a look
uh asleep poor bernie sanders
he looked miserable and completely
uninterested
i don't know looks like he thought he
was in vermont as i said on the radio
this afternoon
the inaugural address sounded more like
an
uninspired student council well high
school student council president
acceptance speech from a guy
who desperately was craving a nap and of
course the main
theme of the speech it was unity after
four years of outright lying conspiracy
theories
witch hunts one hoax after another
vitriol non-stop hysteria two
impeachments including one that is still
unconstitutionally ongoing biden's
hollow calls for unity are both
laughable and completely disingenuous
total and complete bs
well cheap basically bumper stickers and
old worn out liberal socialist cliches
take a look
to restore the soul and secure the
future of america
requires so much more than words
it requires the most elusive of all
things in a democracy
unity this is a bunch of scumbags
that's what they are those are very
strong words organized around making
money
my whole soul is in this bringing
america together
uniting our people united in our nation
you cannot be civil with a political
party that wants to
destroy what you stand for what you care
about
with unity we can do great things
important things the president is a
racist and he is a demagogue
that is just a fact for without unity
there is no peace only bitterness and
fury
this administration is behaving like a
bunch of thugs and gangsters
we must end this uncivil war and
sadly the domestic enemies to our voting
system
and our honoring our constitution are
right at 1600 pennsylvania avenue with
their allies
in the congress of the united states we
can do this
if we open our souls instead of
hardening our hearts
the question is how are we going to
really almost deprogram these people who
have signed up
for the cult of trump you need to be
deprogrammed you're in a cult of trump
re-education camps for you and your
children
so send them a pbs torture camp every
day for 24 hours a day
after they take your kids away from you
now if biden
truly wanted unity instead of just words
and just cliches
he would have started by ending the
vitriol in his own party
for example he could have stopped
comparing republicans to nazis like he
did a week ago
he could ask his colleagues to stop
referring to 75 million peace-loving
trump supporters as domestic terrorists
that support
insurrection when they absolutely do not
he could call for an end to the
unconstitutionally
post-presidential impeachment surveyed
he could also apologize for the russia
hoax
and all those lies and the ukrainian
impeachment
mark my words this will never happen
biden
and now his radicals and power and his
party
they don't give a rip about unity
slogans
bumper stickers flat out lies and
smears continue that doesn't matter to
the mob in the media either by the way
fox news alert starting at 12 noon today
99 plus percent of the media mob
in this country they officially started
what will be
pretty much a four years long vacation
the hard-hitting questions will be gone
the combative press conference is
over the investigative reports with one
anonymous source after another that'll
be a thing of the past
the tingling sensation up and down the
media mob's legs
well they are throbbing like never
before after
four years without obama gasms they're
finally back today
tonight yesterday the editor at the new
york toilet paper times tweeting
biden landing at joint base andrews now
i have
chills the chills are back the thrills
are back
over there at propaganda network
conspiracy channel
all things leftist socialist msdnc their
contributor actually compared biden
to god the father almighty far left
wannabe comedian jimmy kimmel
tweeting congrats to our new president
we know you will do your best to make
america
good again wonder if he's going to
attack jill biden the way he did
uh melania trump oprah winfrey declaring
that
decency and compassion have been
restored hallelujah
do they ever watch any news real news
apparently not because they're clueless
about what the reality of the democratic
party
and the rhetoric of the left is and has
been
make no mistake the thrills the chills
they are officially back tonight in the
usa
take a look fights that are that are
just shooting out from the lincoln
memorial uh along the reflecting pool
i look it's like almost extensions of
joe biden's arms
embracing america it was a moment
where the new president came to town and
sort of convened the country
in this moment of remembrance
outstretching
his arms president-elect joe biden and
vice president harris
pulled the grief and regret
out of the privacy of our hearts if just
for a moment so that we all could share
it
what a beautiful step so i'm i'm gonna
you know i'm reminded of the psalmist
you know he heals the brokenhearted and
binds up their wounds
what a story though what a great love
story between
jill biden and joe biden and the way
that she helped his family recover
from tragedy you know to bring joe back
from what he lost it's it's a wonderful
story and we haven't had a love story in
the white house
in four years you know he spoke from the
depth of his soul
and we needed this you know that was
beautiful
you know beauty heals beauty heals
there was not one part of that that
wasn't just medicine
in the wound he is the better angel
president
joe biden believes he's he's eternally
optimistic
he's not cynical the guy's been in
washington so long you would think you
know some of us
you're here too long and you become
cynical
maybe you at home feel like i do you
probably want to puke
do they have any shame at all now let's
for reference let's travel
back in time four years ago today
let's listen to how the media mob
treated president trump
during his inauguration slight
difference you might notice take a look
this image posted by vox shows the 2009
inauguration of now former president
obama on the left
and trump's inauguration were there on
the right with far fewer spectators
he said today america first it was not
just the racial
i mean i shouldn't say racial the
hitlerian background to it
there were some pockets of protests some
clashes with police more than 200 people
were arrested
but the crowds for the inauguration
appeared to be smaller than they were
four years ago american carnage
not the metal tour but the presidential
inaugural address theme
bang your head a lot of americans
proverbially
did that today he basically took the
hide off everybody sitting on that
platform
we're going to be unpacking this speech
for it'll take us the rest of the day to
get around to this i'm not quite sure
i've ever heard
any inauguration speech quite like this
what does that mean anyway i don't know
anyway every single day for four plus
years that is exactly what we
heard and witnessed from the mob in the
media forgive them father at this point
i don't think they know what they do
they were nasty they were abusively
corrupt and biased and dishonest
unrelenting naturally the vitriol it
continues to this day
right now by the way even during their
joyous praise of all things
joe biden and kamala harris the mob and
the media found time for their favorite
obsession
never stop hating donald trump ever ever
ever
apparently trump lives in their heads 24
7. take a look
well president trump is ending his time
at the white house much like he began it
defiant
avoiding responsibility for creating
chaos
the disgraced 45th president of the
united states
and first lady melania trump
walking to marine one he looks small
he just looks like a small man a
president
who felt neither connected to that
tradition
nor at many times to a constitution that
he believed
did not apply to him it's going to be a
little pathetic a tiny little crowd at
joint base andrews
where he's going to say goodbye he's
almost leaving town like a
uh an autocrat ousted from power
heading off into exile donald trump was
true to himself
not fake not phony and he's kind of
being honest
you know what i think go have your day
and uh i don't need to be here but if
you listen closely from fake news jim
acosta
he might be on to something he talked
about president
trump in exile okay
jim whatever you wish fake news jim
acosta because here's the thing
the american people get to decide who
lives
at 1600 pennsylvania avenue and in four
years they could very easily decide to
bring the president back
for a second term and your hate will
continue
assuming senate republicans of course
are not stupid and fracture the
republican party
completely enforce america first
conservatives into splitting off into
another party which would be a disaster
which i don't think would happen but
he's on to something here president
trump and exile
fine we'll follow jim's lead no matter
what happens moving forward
here's our promise to you we will always
be independent we'll be fiercely
independent we'll always do our best to
bring you the truth
when the mob will never do that we're
not them we'll never be them
over the next four years we will
continue to vet joe biden
we'll stop his radical socialist agenda
anywhere and everywhere we can
for the good of the country and let's
not forget about our ongoing hannity
investigation
into the corrupt biden foreign family
business
we are told that i've been told and i've
been briefed by people that know that
the contents
of hunter biden's laptop are beyond
disturbing
and tomorrow we're going to have right
here on this show a must-see
interview with the owner of that
computer repair shop
you know he's the one that copied the
hard drive
on hunter's laptop and handed it over to
federal authorities that sat on it for a
long time
that's the one that big tech didn't want
to report on before the election
we'll have that exclusive tomorrow